I think, I think the creative, they,
they obviously trust that creative people at Nintendo and they obviously let
them do the crazy ideas. Like they released the Mario cart like AI. Uh,
did you see that, like at your own Aussie calls with cameras in them?
Oh no. I saw that. I saw that rock and it's so cool.
And I didn't have a set of people.
Do this cause I don't have to live in rooms. I actually, I actually,
I actually do, but I mean, most people,
I also the thought of having to put a track down and then.
Yeah, exactly. Just the whole concept of Mario maker. Right?
Like in Hollywood they were embracing like their fans creative side. Yeah.
I love watching Mario making videos, so cool. But no, but,
but at the same time they like Mario party online. No, I never heard of that.
Oh, that's the biggest missed opportunity.
You just said three magical words that I didn't think I needed to hear.
And then I was just like, why, why, why have I never thought of this before?
It's like that meme of like whisper the three sixties.
I can't believe they released super Mario party on like two in 2000,
like 18 months.
And it didn't have online play and had like full maps and they was. Sorry. I,
yeah, I was so disappointed because I love Mario Paul.
It's still good land, but you know, online would be amazing.
Okay.
Do you feel that some part of the Mary potty experiences being next to each
other and just, I get that like the option to do like online the streaming,
right. If I need to, you know, it's the same thing with like smash, right?
Like yeah. Yeah. Playing smash land,
like next to your friends and cheating on them. IRL is fun as. Yeah.
But we very quickly found out that online is also just as fun.
It's like a discord Cole like that fun as far.
I mean, I, I feel like they just hate happiness sometimes.
It's like I thought when,
when super Meyer potty release has gotten way too much detail,
they had like full maps and they were all mid and I was like, okay,
well they'll release new ones. Right. They'll update it. They'll love DLC.
Right. A liar. So that never happened. So I guess, dude,
I'm still sad about that, but then it could have been something good. Yeah.
I'm always just hoping next Maria parties is the one that's going to be online.
The problem with it is like,
everyone else is playing chess and they're just playing hungry hippos,
something like that. Sometimes, sometimes it's fun as.
But other times you're just like,
can you just go back to like a little bit of chess? You know? Like,
like play by the rules just a little bit. You know.
I get it because you know, we live in Japan and they, they develop the games.
I do not know of any Japanese people who go around to each other's houses.
What do you mean? You never know.
Here are people, Japanese people meeting in that other people's houses.
It's always at an ease a or another place.
Yeah. Maybe it's just because you don't have that many Japanese ones.
I do have never do that. Oh, I do that with my Japanese friends. I mean,
not obviously, not this year, not near as often.
As like going out to like eat in these.
A car. Oh yeah, of course. But like,
there's been a lot of cases where I would go out to eat and then we would go
back to someone's place.
It's like, I feel like in the West,
we all like 90% of the time it's like meet up at each other's house,
get a few drinks.
It's expensive to eat out. Whereas here it's like just like cheap.
Yeah. It's like the opposite where it's like,
I feel like for a country that should value what seems to be like online,
play more.
For some reason they don't include it.
Not because they don't need more like reasons to stay at home.
That's already a big enough problem.
[inaudible] was colluding with a gun to get all the Japanese people telling us,
like we're saving this generation from more Shiki. Komori.
Ariel potty is Japanese. Uh Twista.
I felt like this is how we get them to invite them.
Why mailings face like, look.
Like I said something super racist.
Mario party and chill.
[inaudible] rather crate,
like the next Tron VR sex machine toy.
Then they would marry your party online. Let's be honest guys.
What was the thing we were talking about before we get, and it was the,
it was the tango that operates with VR one. Yeah. Yeah.
Have you seen that? It's like, so to explain,
I can't believe I'm explaining tango Tenga.
So Tinga is just like an owner hall or like a Fleshlight Fleshlight. Basically.
You stick your penis in it, but it's bliss branded.
So it doesn't look like a Fleshlight. It's like really way too overly stylish.
It's a classic. It's a classic, a deodorant bottle. It's like a classy pocket.
That's what it is. But we got a colon first class pocket.
I hate that word pocket. I feel so wrong.
Just call it the tango.
But basically Tinga came out with this thing where it would it's machine
operated with like AI in it.
And it works in tandem with VR porn.
So you'd be watching VR.
So you put this thing on your Willie and you don't have to touch it at all.
You start the VR porn and the thing will move in time with what you're seeing on
the VR porn.
I don't want, I don't want that. I don't want that go to a brothel, bro.
That's the first thing I think I'm like, just at that point,
just go get laid by a real person please. That's that's like,
you're paying more for that tech. Then one session out of both.
You know, going to the brothel is a bit different. I think you gotta, you gotta,
you know, you've gotta be the kind of person who's like, all right,
I'm gonna go to a brothel. I get it. You know,
you'll probably if you want sex that badly,
but you're too shameful to go to a brothel. I get it. You're going to pay light.
Walt. I don't know, 20 grand, then it's in your house. Right?
She never have visitors over.
Exactly. Really? What does that, what is that like magical device in the corner.
Oh, that's that's my second. I saw like a video of it. It's straight up.
It looks like a torture device. If you don't know, if you don't know what it is.
I saw that on the news,
they had a thing here where the government was commissioning,
like AI companies to like match people together, which is the,
the birth rates declining so low.
I also feel like that's going into like dystopian worlds.
[inaudible].
Well, that exists where we AI matching each other.
But then also having sex machines that cater for your every need. Yeah.
Why would I, why would I sign up to the AI match?
Like 50 shades of gray in like 2050 is just like,
this guy just brings out his VR sex machine. Why, why,
why would I, why would I sign up for [inaudible]
? Would you like he's he's not romancing a real guy. He's romancing
an anime girl. Why would I need to sign up for him?
Making what I have to like come Tron 7,000 in my office? You know what I mean?
Even with the AI determined, like how do you even determine that? I don't know.
You'll probably just see your star sign seems to be matched very well.
Capricorns at Sagittarius tend to very well knowing Japanese it'd probably be
something like, Oh, it'll be,
it'll be blood type learning and male to female and it'll be right. That's good.
You're compatible with half the population. Fantastic. Nothing has changed.
I don't get Japan's obsession with blood types, man. That's weird.